[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute messbar
guten abend und willkommen zum
nachrichtenüberblick an diesem freitag
an meiner seite ist für den sport
norbert könig zu werben und das sind die
themen von heute
auf dem weg in die europäische union die
eu kommission empfiehlt dass die ukraine
und moldau beitrittskandidaten werden
das gas könnte knapp werden und die
debatte ums energiesparen nimmt fahrt
auf auch entsprechende gesetze werden
diskutiert
und vorbereitung auf die große hitze
morgen werden in teilen deutschlands
rekord temperaturen erwartet
die ukraine wird vermutlich noch jahre
auf eine eu-mitgliedschaft warten müssen
eine garantie hat sie auch nicht und
trotzdem ist das heute ein wichtiger tag
für das land im krieg die eu kommission
hat ihren mitgliedsländern empfohlen die
ukraine und moldau offiziell zur
kandidatin für den eben beitritt zu
nennen madonna hat mehr
ein zeichen der solidarität in richtung
ukraine sendet die eu kommission aus
brüssel auch wenn sie ihre empfehlung an
harte auflagen knüpfen
die ukraine verdient eine europäische
perspektive sollte als beitrittskandidat
willkommen geheißen werden denn gute
arbeit wurde schon geleistet aber es
bleibt noch wichtige arbeit zu tun
der ukrainische präsident bedankt sich
auf twitter an spricht von einer
historischen entscheidung den weg dafür
bereitet haben jene regierungschefs die
mit dem bundeskanzler gestern erst innen
und später kiew besuchten zu den
auflagen der kommission gehört eine
aktive bekämpfung der korruption im land
viel wurde schon erreicht berichtet der
chef von transparency international
ukraine aus geologischen folge
zusätzliche auflagen für die regierung
sind gut das wird unsere arbeit
einfacher machen weil es uns die
argumente liefert kampf gegen die
korruption im land zu verbessern
neben der ukraine empfiehlt die
eu-kommission auf der republik moldau
den status des beitritts kandidaten zu
verleihen damit würden sich beide länder
einreihen in die gruppe jener die schon
seit langem in der warteschlange sind
nun müssen die zweifler mit ins boot
geholt werden wie zb die niederlande die
gegen eine sonderbehandlung der ukraine
war
wir hatten befürchtet dass die eu
kommission das will aber sie hat einen
guten mittelweg gefunden europa lebt vom
kompromiss den können wir jetzt
unterstützen
einstimmig müssen die staats und
regierungschefs nächste woche
entscheiden ob sie den vorschlag der
eu-kommission folgenden
fragen wie grüner krüger in brüssel
welche vorbehalte gibt es gegen diesen
kandidatenstatus für die ukraine und
warum werden beim gipfel kommende woche
vermutlich trotzdem alle zustimmen kurz
gesagt weil die eu kommission heute an
ihre entscheidung ein preisschild
angehängt hat das offensichtlich sogar
den größten kritikern groß genug ist die
ukraine soll sieben defizite beheben da
geht es vor allem darum schon bestehende
gesetze auch anzuwenden so soll sie also
schnell staatsanwälte benennen die dann
auch korruption im land bekämpfen sollen
bei ursula von der leyen da war heute
schon das gelb-blaue outfit die
botschaft sie möchte diesen status für
die ukraine mit jeder faser und vor
allem möchte sie zuerst den status und
dann die reform und länder wie dänemark
oder die niederlande
die hatten eigentlich genau das
gegenteil gefordert aber bis heute
nachmittag haben beide signalisiert sie
möchten dem traum der ukraine jetzt
nicht mehr im wege stehen und dann
bliebe noch österreich dass sie mal sagt
man sollte jetzt eben auch auf den
balkan schauen auf die mitgliedstaaten
auf die staaten die auch einmal google
mitglied werden wollen und am ende
bleibt noch ungarn das immer quer
schießen kann aber es stimmt es ist
schon mehr als eine vermutung dass
nächste woche 27 staats und
regierungschefs hier ja sagen zu einem
status für die ukraine als
beitrittskandidat dankeschön für diese
einschätzung aus brüssel gunnar krüger
war das und die reaktion russlands
wir haben nichts gegen einen eu beitritt
der ukraine sagte präsident putin heute
und attackierte zugleich schafft den
westen auf dem wirtschaftsforum in sankt
petersburg warf putin den usa voran
länder kolonialisieren zu wollen
außerdem sagte er die westlichen
sanktionen hätten ihre wirkung verfehlt
versuche die russische wirtschaft zu
schwächen seien gescheitert
russland liefert immer weniger gas nach
deutschland die speicher hierzulande
sind erst gut zur hälfte gefüllt die
netzagentur sagt die versorgung sei
derzeit stabil aber sie spricht heute
zum ersten mal von einer angespannten
lage ein vorschlag um gas zu sparen
weniger heizen bislang müssen vermieter
die heizanlage so einstellen dass
wohnräume tagsüber mindestens 20 grad
warm werden in der diskussion eine
absenkung der vorgaben auf 18 grad und
zumutbar und unsinnig sahen kritiker
karl hinterleitner hat mehr
die heizung runter weniger autofahren
dinge die jeder tun kann um energie zu
sparen freiwillig doch falls das gas
knapp wird reicht das vielleicht nicht
die gesetzlich garantierten 20 grad in
haushalten sollte man absenken meinen
vertreter von wohnungsunternehmen
wir würden anregend wie diesen
extremfall gar mangelsituationen was
eine katastrophale situation für
deutschland wäre um jeweils zwei grad
diese temperaturen abzusenken die
mieterverbände sind dagegen staatliche
einmischung sei nicht nötig und treffe
die falschen
wir erhalten von einer von einem
staatlich verordneten wärmedecke
überhaupt nichts wir sind der auffassung
dass dabei eine ganze menge menschen
überhaupt nicht berücksichtigt werden
nämlich zum beispiel diejenigen die
älter sind oder krankheiten haben
weswegen sie eine etwas höhere
temperatur benötigen als andere
all das ist vielleicht erst der anfang
sollten die gasvorräte für den winter
nicht reichen für den fall müsste der
staat das sparen verordnet lasst uns
jetzt energiesparen lasst uns jetzt gas
sparen damit wir die unabhängigkeit
hochhalten können das ist ein appell an
die unternehmen aber auch an die
bürgerinnen die bürger aber wir müssen
ist analysieren und wenn die
speichermenge nicht zu nehmen dann
werden wir weitere maßnahmen zur
einsparung zur not auch gesetzlich
vornehmen müssen ob gesetzliche
sparzwänge wirklich kommen ist noch
ungewiss es hängt davon ab ob russland
den gashahn zudreht
überraschende umfrageergebnisse vom
politbarometer hat matthias fornoff
mitgebracht beginnen wir mit der ukraine
politik guten abend der bundesregierung
wie wird die bewährte ja manchen geht
die unterstützung nicht schnell und
nicht weit genug die befragten im
politbarometer aber sehen dass
mehrheitlich nicht so die unterstützung
ist es so genau richtig sagen 43 prozent
33 prozent finden die bundesregierung
tut zu wenig und 16 prozent sieht zu
viel
der westen hat der ukraine schon schwere
waffen geliefert und will das auch
weiterhin tun wird die ukraine dadurch
den krieg gewinnen gut jeder vierte ist
davon überzeugt eine klare mehrheit von
64 prozent aber glaubt nicht dass die
ukraine den krieg gegen russland
gewinnen wird dieser krieg hat die
energiekosten enorm nach oben getrieben
um das abzufedern gibt es auch dass neun
euro ticket wie kommt das an das kommt
so richtig gut an das sehen wir hier in
der nächsten grafik fast drei viertel
finden dass neun euro ticket für drei
monate gut dass busse und bahnen deshalb
dauerhaft mehr genutzt werden bezweifeln
aber 80 prozent der befragten schauen
wir noch auf das kräfteverhältnis der
parteien
wenn am sonntag bundestagswahl wäre käme
die spd auf 22 prozent die union auf 26
beide unverändert grüne 25 +1 fdp 6
minus 1 die fdp bleibt bei zehn prozent
und die linke 5 prozent plus 1
union und grüne können damit sicher
besser leben als die spd und vor allem
die fdp dankeschön matthias seien immer
wieder interessant das komplette
politbarometer mit allen zahlen gibt es
heute abend im heute journal um 22 uhr
wer führt künftig die afd auf dem
parteitag bis sonntag steht die wahl
eines neuen bundesvorstands an nach dem
rücktritt von co- parteichef jörg butt
damit droht der tief gespaltenen partei
ein machtkampf und richtungsstreit klar
ist die laune dürfte schlecht sein nach
wahlschlappen in serie wie bei der
bundestagswahl minus 2,3 prozentpunkte
oder bei den landtagswahlen verluste im
saarland minus 2 prozentpunkte in nrw in
schleswig-holstein flog die afg sogar
ganz aus dem parlament über
entscheidende tage im sächsischen riesa
christiane hübscher es läuft nicht rund
für kino copala nach zweieinhalb jahren
an der fdp-spitze steht die partei
völlig zerstritten ein schicksals
wochenende mit 600 delegierten hier
wollen wir heute gemeinsam die
destruktive stimmung der vergangenen
zeit hinter uns lassen auf diesem
parteitag muss ein bundesvorstand
gewählt werden der kollegial und
konstruktiv vertrauens und
rücksichtsvoll zusammenarbeit die afg
hat selten gute erfahrungen gemacht mit
der doppelspitze fast jedes führungsteam
brach vorzeitig auseinander zeit für
einen aus der deckung zu kommen hier in
riesa
ich bekenne mich zur einzel spitze das
bedeutet führung in freiheit und
verantwortung aufteilen die afg nimmt
turcas antrag mit fast 70 prozent
zustimmung an künftig also kann es einen
oder zwei vorsitzende geben ein erfolg
für den umstrittenen thüringer
landeschef der vom verfassungsschutz als
rechtsextrem ist beobachtet wird selbst
antreten wird hocke diesmal wohl nicht
grob anna aber will weitermachen und
wenn zu zweit dann am liebsten mit alice
weidl die sich noch ziert ich schließe
es nicht aus kommt auf die kandidaten an
die auch noch wollen mindestens zwei
wollen noch haben ihre kandidatur schon
offiziell angekündigt gelten aber als
chancenlos die einzige inhaltliche
entscheidung bisher in riesa die fdp
fordert mit großer mehrheit den bau
neuer kernkraftwerke
jetzt zu corona für kinder und
jugendliche war und ist die pandemie
eine schwere zeit darauf weist der
berufsverband der kinder und jugendärzte
hin immer mehr hätten depressionen und
emotionale störungen
klinikeinweisungen bei jugendlichen
hätten im vergangenen jahr um mehr als
40 prozent zugenommen
die forderungen der ärzte deshalb
schulen offen lassen auch bei steigenden
fallzahlen um alesco war jakob maske hat
viel zu tun derzeit der kinderarzt sieht
häufiger patienten mit zwangsstörungen
oder ängsten folgeerscheinungen der
pandemie in dem maße habe er bestimmte
erkrankungen noch nicht erlebt sehen
natürlich kinder und jugendliche die
enorm an gewicht zugenommen haben die
teilweise in einem jahr 20 bis 30
kilogramm zugenommen haben gewichts
verhältnisse die wir vorher noch nie
gesehen haben wir sehen im gegenteil
aber auch kinder die essstörung haben
und eben sehr stark abnehmen auch viele
lehrerinnen und lehrer registrieren
zunehmender verhaltensauffälligkeiten
laut einer befragung im auftrag der
robert bosch stiftung bemerkten im
letzten september 67 prozent
konzentrationsmängel bei schülern
aktuell sind es 82 prozent
aggressives verhalten verdoppelte sich
fast von 23 auf jetzt 42 prozent
schulpsychologen sind alarmiert sie
fordern in den klassen druck
rauszunehmen dass wir auch in den
schulen beginnen
mehr beziehung mehr emotionale soziale
arbeit zu leisten und notengebung
inhalte curriculum lernplan etwas hinten
anstellen sonst muss mir wirklich
befürchten dass sich das verstärkt auch
außerhalb der schule müssten die
hilfsangebote verbessert werden gerade
bei psychischen problemen fordern die
kinderärzte mehr therapieplätze schaffen
für die schon erkrankten kinder oder mit
psychiatrischen symptomen für seine
patienten hofft jakob maske dass schulen
und kitas im winter dauerhaft nicht mehr
schließen müssen selbst wenn die korona
zahlen nochmal deutlich steigen sollten
die britische regierung will
wikileaks-gründer assange an die usa
ausliefern innenministerin patel
unterzeichnete eine entsprechende
anweisung
assange hat nun 14 tage zeit gegen die
entscheidung juristisch vorzugehen in
den usa drohen dem australier bis zu
175 jahre haft ihm wird vorgeworfen
geheime unterlagen von us
militäreinsätzen veröffentlicht zu haben
heute ist welttag gegen wüstenbildung
und dürre klare folgen des klimawandels
besonders sichtbar werden diese dort wo
es eh schon heiß und trocken ist die
indische büßte in rajasthan zum beispiel
die sommer in der region werden von jahr
zu jahr extremer kaum erträgliche 51
grad wurden dort bereits gemessen die
folge die wüste breitet sich immer
weiter aus normen odenthal
von klein auf hat bald gelernt die
ziegen zu hüten heute ist der 74 hat
vier kinder von denen keins in seine
fußstapfen tritt sie sind weggezogen
denn bauer zu seinen rajasthan das ist
ein hartes brot
auf diesem boden wächst kaum noch gras
früher stand es so hoch wir hatten
futter für die tiere im überfluss unsere
vorräte reichten für 45 jahre jetzt
reicht es noch nicht einmal für ein jahr
wenn gott gibt dann haben wir wenn nicht
dann sterben unsere tiere
geben meint vor allem regen geben aber
klimawandel heißt hier es regnet kaum
noch wird immer heißer das land immer
karger das einzige was wirklich wächst
ist die wüste selbst die höchste breitet
sich rasant aus futterpflanzen gibt es
kaum noch es wird furchtbar schwierig
das ökosystem ihr zu retten wir
versuchen unser bestes mit
traditionellen techniken die pflanzen zu
bewässern
neben die letzten busse buddeln sie
tontöpfe ein das wasser ist nach 20
tagen raus gesichert nachschub muss ein
tankwagen bringen und topf für topf wird
wieder aufgefüllt extrem mühsam aber
jeder weiß worum es geht
klar belegt dass in diesen dürreperioden
viele bauern die sonst schon nahe der
armutsgrenze leben ist unter die
armutsgrenze gedrückt werden armut index
und dürre index hängen eindeutig
zusammen
der klimawandel bedroht das land und
seine menschen in rajasthan wächst die
wüste und mit ihr die sorgen die man ihr
noch leben soll
es ist kein vergleich zur hitze in der
wüste aber für unsere verhältnisse wird
das wochenende richtig heiß mit
temperaturen bis zu 40 grad was das
bedeutet und was zum schutz wichtig ist
zeigt christopher heinze
balkone und terrassen des bruder konrad
stift in der mainzer innenstadt am
nachmittag
menschenleer es ist schon heute zu heiß
drinnen heißt die devise trinken trinken
trinken
die gefahr für bettlägerige menschen bei
diesen temperaturen zu dehydrieren
besonders hoch zudem bereitet das
pflegepersonal die bewohner auf das
hitze wochenende vor wir versuchen die
leute anzuleiten da sie was leichteres
anziehen nicht so viele jacken oder
nicht so viel warme pullover dass wir
rechtzeitig die rollläden runterlassen
dass es einfach ein bisschen kühler ist
im zimmer und die mittagspause
vielleicht einfach etwas ausgedehnter
machen
freiburg im breisgau hier könnten am
wochenende rekorde geknackt werden
temperaturen bis zu 40 grad das gab es
in baden-württemberg mitte juni noch nie
morgen wird es vor allem im westen und
im südwesten besonders heiß temperaturen
bis 39 grad sind sogar 40 grad drin aber
es hängt so ein bisschen davon ab ob wir
saharastaub dann direkt ab bekommen oder
nicht kommt der sahara staub wenn die
temperaturen etwas gedämpft werden
plätze wie diese am wochenende
sicherlich in vielen teilen deutschlands
heiß begehrt
mit zahlreichen gedenkveranstaltungen
ist heute an den ddr volksaufstand vom
17 juni 1953
erinnert worden berlins regierende
bürgermeisterin giffey und
bundesbauministerium geiwitz legten am
mahnmal auf dem friedhof seestraße
kränze nieder von 69 jahren war es in
der ddr zu protesten gekommen die von
der sowjet armee gewaltsam
niedergeschlagen wurden mehr als 50
menschen wurden getötet bis zu 15.000
verhaftet
und jetzt der sport freude bei den
deutschen tennis-fans fans cents aus der
orte bleibt am ball der nadel in der
ferne genau
er selbst findet das einfach nur
unfassbar wie schon vor einer woche in
stuttgart steht oskar otte im halbfinale
und wie schon gestern hat er sich in
halle in westfalen durchgekämpft nach
verlorenem ersten satz gegen den grossen
carina chernoff
der dank ans publikum wahrhaft herzlich
die zuschauer haben ausbau orte getragen
durch achtel und viertelfinale und
seinen größten erfolg möglich gemacht
ich sowohl hier generell in deutschland
und zu hause so nah und zu hause und ist
einfach ein geiles gefühl hier zum
beispiel einzustellen nach verlorenem
ersten satz kämpfte er sich zurück
gewinnt den tie-break des zweiten und
schafft im entscheidenden dritten satz
das break zum 3 2
nach zwei stunden und elf minuten hat
der kölner match ball und verwandelt ihn
mit druck und rezession
es ist der zweite halbfinal einzug
innerhalb einer woche für den neuen
punktekurs liebling in halle
mensch wächst an seinen aufgaben ortes
gegner morgen ist der
weltranglisten-erste daniel medwedew
live im zdf ab 14 uhr 15
bayern freut sich auf den superstar laut
verschiedener medienberichte hat der fc
liverpool grünes licht gegeben für den
wechsel von stürmer sah der mann zum
deutschen rekordmeister sein bundesliga
debüt könnte der senegalese in genau
sieben wochen geben
der meister darf zuerst spielen nach
zehn titeln in serie müssen die bayern
allerdings nach frankfurt beim letzten
mal konnten sie hier drei punkte
mitnehmen da war die eintracht aber auch
noch nicht europa league sieger 15
spieltage sind es bis zur wm im november
die nationalspieler der champions league
vereine könnten auf belastende 26
pflichtspiele in 15 wochen kommen die
sorgen haben die berliner clubs nicht in
dem maß union gegen hertha ist der
hauptstadt der bundesliga auftakt und
alle vereine wie auch der vom aufsteiger
auf schalke müssen sich was einfallen
lassen wie die wm bedingte wochenlange
ligapause am besten überbrückt werden
kann
manche richtig stress auch für die fans
ich danke der
details zur hitze und zum wetter morgen
liefert gleich erst intelli christian
sievers freut sich auf sie im heute
journal um 10 und das gesamte 19 uhr
team wünscht ihnen ein schönes
wochenende
bis morgen wenn sie mögen auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
schon gut und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter den höhepunkt der aktuellen
hitzewelle den erwarten wir morgen die
hitze kommt von nordafrika über spanien
frankreich bis nach deutschland und
häufig werden temperaturen um die 40
grad marke erwartet in frankreich und in
spanien aber auch im westen deutschlands
ist diese marke in sicht wir schauen in
die nacht er wird im westen aufklaren
sonst sind harmlose wolken unterwegs und
es ist überall trocken bei tiefsten
temperaturen von 19 grad im westen und
10 grad im südosten deutschlands lüften
sie nochmal ordentlich durch denn es
wird morgen heißt bei viel sonnenschein
vor allem im süden deutschlands und im
osten sonst sind die wolken harmlos es
fällt kaum etwas aus den wolken
temperaturen dazu bis 39 grad geht es im
südwesten auf örtlich kann es bis zu 40
rangehen und ganz im norden 21 bis 24
grad deutlich erträglicher noch einmal
39 grad am sonntag vor allem im süden
viel sonnenschein sonst schauer und
gewitter die vereinzelt auch im unwetter
bereich liegen können damit ein verdammt